okay
hello to everybody joining the live
stream this
is a meeting about language completeness
and consistency
and we have a variety of topics here so
the first topic is progress about
progress
correct so you asked for a progress
report on
the progress indicator project so
here this is basically the report so we
have a bunch of functions listed there
that have been updated and a number
that are in the process of being updated
um then we have a bunch more of smaller
ones that have
are on sort of the list to be updated
and maybe at this point we should just
be filing bugs
and telling people hey because right i
don't think it's
reasonable to ask giulio to go and
update everybody else's code so we
probably should just be filing bugs and
telling people hey you need to do this
question how many of these are enhanced
progress and how many of them are just
a blue thing with a with a progress bar
going across
many of them are just a blue thing even
without the bar
for example if you open the data pack
let's you see
do i need prototype build or do i need
head branch build
uh no i mean this is uh stuff is in the
head but the
the point is that you have stuff like uh
mortality data
and when you when you start it up it
says initializing mortality data
that we'll just need to switch to the
new basically
panel layout i mean it will happen has
it happened or is it not
i mean okay so not for every data
okay so if i say weather forecast data
i don't know what it's going to give me
but if i just do it you get give it like
you know
a city give it boston or whatever
okay
oh that was so fast too fast
we're waiting no progress
i think this one has a as a delay of
five seconds it does six or five seconds
that's the
choice of the developer uh the they can
update the updated interval
but because i mean in this case you you
saw it for like uh
yeah ten five sometimes in europe i get
like 20 20
to 25 seconds so it's you see it for
quite a bit of time
depending on what you ask for but have
we got standards for how long to make
people wait before they see things
the you the default is two seconds
i i believe that web focus data is doing
something
else before downloading uh
okay well i think i i i mean there was
uh as i recall there was something in
the
way that they are batching their data
that made it difficult
to to sort of get really fine-grained
um you know
information i i you know something like
video
something like you know video processing
what it's sort of much more detailed
right i mean there
they have you know right there's phase
one and phase two
and if you're exporting to an mp4 and
and you know sort of i guess the first
one doesn't have a time estimate and the
second one does
um can i ask a question what what
um if i look for functions that have
time constraint
as an option
if i say select a name star
i mean i think somebody else could do
this um
let's see what do i want to say member
queue
options of hash comma
time constraint
what did i get wrong here does options
not allow you to take a a symbol
it may not yeah all right oh right
options interprets uh as uh a string
as uh as the name of uh of a stream
right so like stood out or stood in
ah somebody has the right code
thank you lou
oh my god look at that crazy crazy thing
right because it's evaluating everything
and if necessary autoloading it
it's not working to do well
did finally work
a string of task objects is expected
instead of dollar failed
okay some random bug here okay so these
are these are good places i mean like
full simplify do we have a chance of
of giving anything there that would be
very nice
um we don't have any sort of time
estimate right
no but we do have a what we're doing
doing this doing that doing the other
thing
because if all we did was say running
this dot
dot running that dot dot the thing will
not look like it's just dumb as a stone
right um there are i mean
i guess well well i think
there are certainly some things we could
do with full simplify
um what does geo identify
is that new now that's goes to
ten point something i think yeah it has
been there from the very beginning
what's one of the nearest friends
you identify you're within queue like
you give it a location and it tells you
what's what's there
oh oh oh oh i was thinking it was going
to take some picture
like that that um that neural net
let me tell you right yes sorry okay
there's some weird things in this list
which might be
worth looking at i mean including geo
identify itself
i don't know whether any of these things
can be
you know instrumented i think they're
good yeah
yeah i think the geo ones can i mean the
thing
i think it's go ahead sorry i i think
it's highly used to be able to say i'm
doing this
even if you don't have an estimate of
when it'll be finished
see what i'm saying because it's a sign
of life
right
so okay so hopefully the framework can
support that and we'll go forward in
that direction
yep okay terrific
and and graphic design wise we're we're
all done now right
i think so julia i mean you're making
some refinements but i think those are
all on the back end
not on the visual end right now only
on the back end right although that
frames bug that beat you
is in the process of being fixed so you
may be able to improve the appearance a
bit
once that's fixed uh yeah i have
a i mean i have a refactor of the whole
interface
which makes it a lot more modular so
as soon as i have a little extra time
i'll meet with billy
and i know billy i promise if we meet
with you doesn't have time yet
uh to to basically create an interface
which is
a lot more customizable so design can
just
go wild and fine-tune paddings and sizes
and stuff but
i guess i mean the overall appearance is
set now it's just a matter of
incremental refinements in like the
little spacing things and
stuff like that okay
i mean question are we do we have a user
level
access to this framework not yet
do we have a design sort of i mean it's
kind of uh i mean uh
our intention was to spend this cycle
you know
pushing it out and seeing if there are
any issues and then
you know circle back can i ask for one
thing that i
really want to see which is parallel map
and parallel table
getting something like parallel map
monitored
i mean i've been using parallel map
monitor for a year
and while it's developer max and other
people say oh oh it might give her
incorrect data
let me tell you on a very diverse
collection of parallel tasks
i am very happy with it i th
isn't the the oh it's remote fetch
submit i guess
roman is here so he can talk about the
parallel
uh i don't know yes i mean this is on my
agenda right i mean i've
okay we'll get it done for 12.3 i mean
this is
just imitate you can imitate with the
new graphic design
exactly what parallel map monitor does
and i'll be a happy person
okay it gives you know such and such a
number out of such and such a number
have been done
the percentage and the expected time to
completion
and and you may say oh oh but if they're
all different sizes it won't work blah
blah blah
blah let me tell you it works great
very diverse collection of workloads
okay
and it's perfectly okay if the thing
starts off
saying it's going to be done next year
and it's only done two out of whatever
so it turns out as a user you kind of
get used to that very quickly
oh it's got some difficult ones at the
beginning and then it's going to speed
up
it's fine it doesn't have to be you know
you don't have to be held to when it's
going to come back
it's very good okay
good okay but doing that for parallel
map
and parallel table really worthwhile
okay that makes sense
yes yes okay fine and
i mean it will be very nice to do that
for map
and table well that that that that's a
different or that's a different order of
magnitude no i difficulty
i know i know i know that i know that
yeah i mean that's if it can see if map
can plainly see
that it's going over a huge number of
items that's the case of interest
right but yeah i mean there there i mean
there's a technical obstruction
in that we don't want to introduce
extra calls to the evaluator inside of a
map
yeah and so it's you know it's it's it's
definitely on our to-do list and we're
we're
we're going to try it first with
functions which are
you know less likely to destroy the
whole system if
you're fine if you don't get it right
fine okay so stephen
if you're curious um we are in the
middle of a refactoring
of the wolfram image library and i
discussed that with piotr
and he's open to work with me and test
that to some functions like color negate
some function with big loop
inside the c code so we can we can
actually
benchmark a bit the overhead and test
different strategies
safer environment okay um
let's see what was i going to uh are you
know you're the prototype build now
is it good range of 10 to 6
yep
okay so you see we have a slightly new
appearance with all sorts of new options
in the output size limit
so many many comments here okay first of
all the eight period
that needs to lose the period we need a
way of formatting stuff like that that
does lose the period
yeah i don't know what we have do we
have such a way is it decimal form or
something what is it
do you understand my question i mean
we don't have we don't have a standard
way i mean
we do it i think we should have a
standard way to do it
um i mean i i thought decimal form was a
way to do that
now we removed it from percent form
i see but we need a way to do this
because this comes up all the time
should it be a number form should it be
some kind of presentation form what
should it be
we need a way to do it
it just looks terrible you have some
plot it's an eight point
it's like no
i mean we could always include at least
one digit after the
decimal no we don't want that we don't
want that there's plenty of times
where you have look if i make a table
come on guys
we need to solve this problem not a
different problem right if i say
range of 10 divided by 2 for example
okay and then i say n of that
right i do not want to see one point
if we wait no that that that cannot be
changed no no no not in this case i want
a version of this where i don't see one
point
period end of story this is a variant of
chop
no well yes it could be but that would
turn it into an actual integer
it is a very different right
semantics i know i'm not i'm well i i
might be asking for that
okay i might be asking for that
okay that's a different operation that's
a semantic operation i was just asking
for a presentation thing
right i think perhaps an option to all
the family
of the number forms i don't want that i
want a wrapper because this comes up all
the time
okay well we can we can look into that
okay i i i'm not completely opposed to a
semantic one as well
that changes into an actual integer i
think that might actually be useful
and it certainly won't hurt the
presentation
do you see what i'm saying i kind of i
haven't thought of that and it kind of
seems like a good idea to me
it's kind of like you know round if it's
really close
right it's in integer
fi into jurify
i i think that some of our internal
functions like byte string
is is doing that already
no doubt but what should we call the
actual
right so that'll round right that'll
round to
i mean that's going to give you another
machine precision
thing right right if if you did the if
you
round it to i think one over a thousand
then i think it'll give you the integer
that's even more confused well whatever
whatever it is
okay i think that you're right lou this
is the right approach to actually turn
into integers
so you're right it needs to be something
like chop
um it's like a really strict rationalize
or something
well no not quite but
there's some notion like a snap grid
fiducial you know what i'm saying
snap the
concept of something like a snap grid
it's not quite integer snap doesn't
quite do it for me
um i mean the truth is
that chop and snap might be
might i mean they at least would be snap
is a little weird
but it's something like that
i think there is a difference here
between snapping to a grid
and changing the type converting a real
into an integer
while leaving other numbers still being
reals
what does chop do for zeroes
right it makes
exact zero right i mean i think we could
do something like
yes snap and if it's a number right
right the default would be snap comma
one
right so if it's close to and then you
could do a snap
of point you know
yeah 0.5 or or maybe one half so if it's
close to one of those
it changes it and if not and then you
give it a list
if you want your own custom list of snap
values
i think this is an interesting name snap
actually it's not it's not sounding as
bad as i thought it would be
because i think this is an operation
that people want to do
and i've wanted many many many many many
many times
and i end up with crazy you know tick
specifications and things like this
to avoid this how close does it have to
be to
it's got some tolerance just like chop
has a tolerance
and that's you know that that's the
second argument
um okay anyway this is a good idea so
let's let's
propagate this okay let's look back at
this
okay graphic design wise
this is a particularly drab gray
and i don't think that the i don't like
the fact that these things don't
buttonify
all the way to the top and bottom do we
have some different design here
oh you barely should be here um but
what do you mean it's not but
buttonifying oh i mean dividers are
involved
with dividers yeah i think it would look
clearer it'd be easier to read if the
dividers went all the way steven
shrink the width of this notebook by
half or so
or more than half
are you willing to give up the line
wrapping
no okay so but then we need us okay
fine so we need a solution right i'm
just pointing out the cases
yep that's a good case to point out
um billy are you here
yes okay
this is useful this expression size
thing the spacing looks wrong
here um
you know i would have a feeling that
show more
should say so show double
is that what it's doing
it's increasing the short uh by
a factor of two so if short if one can
rely on short
for doubling then yes it's doubling do
we think that's useful is show
more i mean double does suggest it's
going to you know
it suggests this exponential effect
rather than one more more
because most times when it says show
more it's show the next page
do you understand what i'm saying yeah
so we're less shortening
show hof show double show off yeah
but it's not double or half of the
original expression
don't care at this stage it's show
double
right it's showing double of what's
current or half of what's currently
shown i mean maybe that makes it super
sneaky maybe it's stupid
okay what do other people think
this i mean i never i never
thought that this was somehow not
precise enough because
i would not have expected it to actually
show exactly twice as much
or so all right okay fine all right show
more is okay
okay i can eyes expression lovely
oh no oh yes yeah so unlike an ice is
not
passing through the same limiter
talking about this is it possible to put
the limiter in the output of print
um well this is mathematica all things
are possible
um you could do it i suppose you could
do it yourself
right how what is the output limiter
it's not expo it's it's tied into the
main loop
rather tightly i'm not sure that it's
right but at the end of the day the main
loop is just
calling some yes there's there's some
bulk of of wolf language code i don't
know offhand how one would do this
manually so to speak okay well so maybe
we need a wrapper
that says size limited form
or something like limited form
could do
which is sort of the analog of short but
it's a more dynamic form of short
i mean alternatively maybe we should
make short do this
so i mean one reason that this output
limiter works for
output is that there is a place in the
kernel already where this expression is
stored
right and the down values about if we
were to do this with some arbitrary
other expression we'd need some
new storage space for it
well notice that
we're about to see the story notebook
thing which oh i see store full
expression in notebook
okay that's gonna need an icon to go
along with the other
what the hell is this so the settings
just goes to the preferences
dialog which gives you the limit that
maximum out the third item
there is the relevant item um
it's pretty ugly yeah the the the
settings
there's actually a different spec that i
haven't yet implemented for settings
but everything else but that is a gear
on the right
just put that as a freaking gear on the
right it's a once
how should it look when the notebook is
half as wide
it should just go at the end
what does at the end that you'd have a
middle
cell that's line wrapped
no i would just put it at the end of
this cell here
it's just like it's in the bottom corner
signature yeah it's a signature so to
speak
sure i mean i'm just trying to remove
some text here
i would like to see icons for these
things i think it'll be much easier to
read
um
i mean another thing we could do is we
could group
you know group these yes that would help
show more show all but together i can
eyes expression copy as i can eyes
yeah i think that would be good to to
have them spaced because i
bothers me there's more space here and
by the way i would i would just remove
the parens if you're going to have that
color
change i wouldn't bother with the parens
okay
um billy it would be nice to have a
little bit more life to the color here
okay
some brighter blues maybe something like
that
slightly less gray background maybe
something is bothering me about this i
mean this is
this was the upgrade after you
complained that the old background was
too blue right
okay right it used to be it used to be a
different color
which i think was blue i may be
misremembering
but
i have a v7 open here honestly look
several things about this are better
like the fact that these go to the
bottom is better
see those those things go to the bottom
is is better and if they have to wrap
then then obviously they don't go to the
bottom but they go to the bottom
of their line
okay
i think the lowercase is better
was bothering me here especially in this
case here
and where you've got inconsistent
capitalization come on guys
i would just go lower case unless this
is inconsistent
making sense but you can't muddle up the
capitalization
unless we go to icons and then cases
they're going to be words as well
they're going to be icons and words
ah okay
um
why did we change this i mean i don't
think it's quite right to have
why do we have this footer i mean the
footer has to be consistent with the
footer
on this um of these things right
okay i don't understand why this color
would not be the same as this color here
come on guys
and if you make that color the same
you've got to change this back to our
brands
synchronize we could work to synchronize
some of these uh styles
yes that's what we need to do and this
height is wrong relative to this one et
cetera et cetera
which height is wrong this height here
relative to this height here this is a
ribbon should be the same kind of ribbon
as this ribbon here
well that's uh that's a
button uh right i mean the the ribbon
on the summary box never needs to line
wrap right because it only ever has that
exact text
okay fine but you guys need to sort it
out i don't know what to tell you
but sort it out
okay what are you showing me here is not
a notebook store now
click on it
well first of all the alignment of the
radio buttons with that text is wrong
that
needs to be fixed yeah that's known okay
now first of all are you okay with the
text itself
i'm thinking
i think the first thing should say store
in place in this notebook or store in
this notebook
store in this box is incomprehensible to
somebody who doesn't know internal stuff
do you see what i'm saying yeah i
recognized about that a bit
um i i aired on the side of accuracy but
i
i'm willing to to ease up on that for
clarity
maybe store in line is is clearest
how about store here in this notebook
that well i
i'm going to argue i mean that sounds a
bit long to me and i'm going to
argue again that
for store in line because we have dollar
dollar inline storage limit dollar
notebook inline startup
that makes sense then store in line in
this notebook
[Music]
i'll put out there that your objection
to store in this box
that you dislike because you know too
much about the system
no i don't know what the heck a box is i
understand
there is a box right there there's a
rectangle i know
i know but but it's like saying
something like it's like some crazy
skeuomorphic design where
the thing says you know uh you know
uh fluff your quill it's got a picture
of a pen on a screen
and what the hell does it mean
you know it's got a picture of a quill
pen and it says do you want to fluff
your quill now
what does it mean that's a bad example
but but
you see what i'm saying it's a box on a
screen
store in this box is like you buy it
from a container store or something
you know what i'm saying right
um
i think store online in this notebook is
the most sensible thing
i'm fine with that okay i would suggest
that the um
do we have a non-inline store in the
notebook
we don't yet but we might it's
theoretically conceivable but we don't
currently have one
right okay so my next comment is
i think that
this should say at the top here size
16 megabytes or whatever
and then at the bottom it should just
say store now
you get what i'm saying yeah or either
that or okay
i always wonder with these things where
you first have to
decide what to do and then you have to
hit the button why not have three
buttons
and then it's a one-click operation
right well where would you put those
three buttons right there
right there where the the instead of the
radio box you have three buttons
that's a good point oh i see i i
uh well it's still a two-click operation
right no it's not
oh well
well you need to click it to make the
the whole thing appear
but yes yes but all right so i guess the
claim is instead of having a radio
button
so it's a two-click operation instead of
a a two to three click operation i guess
is the claim this doesn't even really
need to be a separate
i mean this could just be a menu with
three choices in it
right instead of instead of popping up
this attached cell it could just pop up
a menu
yes it could and that's what we do in
the predictive interface for example
and it works pretty well fine
then i think it should say at the bottom
or at the top you know expression size
16 megabytes maybe at the bottom because
there's less mouse motion to get to the
thing you want
i mean it would be nice okay so so with
the menu
the keyboard navigation and we i don't
think we have ux people here do we
do we have ux people here we have
christina right isn't she a us person
hello
yes hello so good so i mean
what we want is something whether where
the keyboard navigation is going to work
so if you press store now and the first
menu item
is i mean how do we do that the first
menu item is the default selected item
or something how do we do that
did you understand what i'm saying
anybody
you want the location of the mouse
pointer to somehow find the first item
well i don't know what because what's
nice about this is that it suggests the
default
okay and many people will find this
completely confusing
and we want to suggest a default
well i mean the the well i'm not sure
what you mean by default right because
you'll have to click on something but
right the normal idiom
is that the default action is
right blue background or has some you
know definite color background
i understand but that doesn't happen
with menus right these
radio buttons are the only things that
have i mean radio buttons no no no i'm
not talking about radio buttons like if
you right if you
open uh uh right the
the open dialog right and you have some
buttons right the default action that's
tied to return
yeah is it has a blue background from
the operating system
or right so if you had something
selected
right then that open button instead of
being grayed out would be
blue right yeah default buttons are
special
okay i agree once it's a button you can
do that but as a pure menu you cannot
so the argument therefore that i'm
making is i agree with roman why not
just have three buttons one of them is
default
and and already highlighted and if you
hit return that's the button that will
be hit done
and that's the button you have
highlighted here
store in line in this notebook did you
understand what i'm saying
i understand uh and
i would need to make sure that return
actually
visits the content of attached cells
before promising that feature
okay fine but but but conceptually
that's that seems like the thing to do
right and then what i would do is i
would probably
um put at the bottom expression size 16
megabytes
okay as a footer
so why does it say 16.0 here or not 16
point
well it shouldn't who knows yeah
i i don't think i think it should be
rounded to the megabyte
i think
you know um yeah tim on our live streams
pointing out combo box can have a
default value
um although this isn't a combo box
because we don't want to display the
the choice at the beginning we only want
it to come up if you press store now
okay so this looks very nice
this looks good it looks like what we
want so long as we can have that default
button there
and on um so there's one case that itai
hasn't mentioned
yet or maybe that's what we're going to
look at right now
um yes okay but the default is different
yes and
the reason and the first one is in fact
grayed out and
inoperable and if you hover over it
maybe does it give you a chance
yes
embed button size limit
why is there a button size limit
there there's an embed size limit
because we don't want people crashing
their front ends because they're trying
to understand but but i don't think it
should say embed button i think it
should just say
by the way maybe we should put given
that wording
instead of storing line in this notebook
in bed
in line in this notebook
why not especially since you're using
embed in the next in the next
phrase because that makes it clear that
this thing is
embedded it's it's part of the document
it's gonna you know be carried around
with the document
as opposed to store it externally in
some file or something
okay but so this expression
this is the limit for
okay with the wording has got to be
consistent here this expression
exceeds the size for notebook
embedding and can only be stored in a
separate file
that sounds good in a separate file not
as a separate file
in a separate file the fact that it is
its own file is a detail
got it okay
all right now what to do with the
graying out hold on one second so let me
just
um
i think it could be a grayed out button
with a question mark after it
okay and it'll say the expression size
at the bottom
uh or
we could just not have that button and
down below the expression size we could
say
too big to embed locally two-bit combat
in this notebook
what do you think
it's less obvious toward not having the
option at all
yeah i think that's right but now
you could be able to use that option if
you um
change the setting for dollar inline
whatever size
no it's a system option so
so dollar inline storage limit is
controls
you know when does it
you know where when do you get that
button
at all but then there's a second option
which is just a system option um
which you know is there if you really
want to shoot yourself in
in in the foot but the reason
we we put that upper limit is because
people were crashing their front ends
trying to store
super large expressions okay
okay so so fine so i i think don't put
the button
um and i would just put size blah blah
and then parens
too large for embedded to too large to
embed in this notebook
right i'm i'm going to i you know i'm
i'm
not viewingly opposed but i'm going to
uh argue the contrary because
if the what we based this off of
was the send mail dialogue
where if it's above 10 megabytes or
whatever is the limit
then you still have the you know
attach the notebook to the the the
attach the notebook
to the email is still
visible but grayed out and you can only
select the
you know send link to cloud or however
it's phrased
right i forget i don't use that dialogue
often enough to know
the phrase well okay i admit yeah i
understand what you're talking about yes
i could go either way on this other
other thoughts from other people
i think it is clear if it's grayed out
because that
otherwise you might wonder why you have
sometimes two or three
and there's also a good place where you
put that information about the size
limit
fine okay fine let's do it by the way
i'd just like to comment on the send
mail
stuff the fact that there is no auto
completion
on send mail on the on the address line
of send mail
just drives me crazy it doesn't even
remember
you know people i've sent it to before
in the product
you know what i'm saying i have a
question that
um i have no idea where the mail system
on a mac or something
gets its contact list from
but you know is it a keychain thing or
is it something
local for the app it's probably a
combination of pulling things from your
contacts and what it's seen before
right so contacts what you know can be
configured
to right be your own local
contacts or boy i'm blanking on the name
ldap right ldap right it can be config
the contacts settings in system
preferences can be configured to
use ldap or various other okay but given
that we now have interaction with the
system keychain i don't see why we can't
have our send mail mechanism
uh you know request that uh i know
i i don't think that's technically a
keychain we could ask for it
it would right prompt a new
warning dialogue from the system saying
you know mathematica is trying to
contact
you know contact your contacts right
but that's fine i mean you know because
that would make it unbelievably much
more usable to me
right because i don't know how to spell
anybody's name anymore because just auto
completes
right the uh anyway
who is who that is that for fakim or
somebody else i don't know who
is working on that right now but that
that's well that's definitely not for
him
um i think lou do you know
what was this a larry project well the
dialogue
was kevin kevin kevin
but as far as how to get how to talk to
the os
to get the completions i i don't know
that
we're not the expert on the on the key
chain if that's relevant
yeah i i think the right person to talk
to would be rob schofield
um okay cool
right except cole is is currently
at least for the time being rob rob is
called because cole is working on the
video
library link in the front end stuff okay
okay so anyway get the question asked
let's figure out the answer to that okay
let's loop back here to the thing at the
top it is really bothering me
that the look of that ribbon at the top
is different from the look of the ribbon
in these in these um
summary boxes but okay
we'll get that straightened out now the
question is
um okay so
that icon the arrow whatchamajig icon
should definitely be the icon for this
store full expression notebook right
yep and then copy is iconized i'm sure
we can have
something which has a little copy thing
with an icon type
type piece
um if
if we're going to combine these into
menus right we could be
and i can eyes in place or copy the
clipboard
or something like that right oh no we
don't want to combine these in the menus
this is fine to ribbon okay
like this the ribbon is fine i just
think it needs icons and it needs a look
it's more like this okay okay and it
needs to
you know this one goes red this one goes
blue i mean come on
okay um
perhaps christina if she was you know
pointed at this would generate would say
all those things in her report i don't
know
but anyway i'm pointing them out thank
you
um
okay anything else to say about this
before we go on to the next item here
yes so um
[Music]
so luke can correct me if i'm wrong but
i think
right now this is going through put and
get
when you okay so we're talking about the
local object storing business
yes okay why aren't we using our max
wxf files because they're not as
faithful
and nor are they as fast i don't think
i mean they may be faster i don't think
they would be as
as fast as um mx-5
yes um
um right and so i guess the question is
i mean
i mean i think with a local object since
it's living on
on your system it's probably fine to use
mx files with cloud objects it's maybe a
bit
and i know maybe maybe we do mx files
for local and
put for why don't we do wxf we
should never use input we should never
use push
no wxf is not accurate enough
it's just fun no wxf
is not accurate enough it cannot
remember just a bug
does it a that's not true and second of
all even if it were true
uh you know i'm not going to introduce a
uh
uh no open the source notebook for
uh open the source notebook for
for for binary serialize
why the source notebook because the
because it's a tentative example
yeah i think the wrong set of people are
here but but if no no
no i was one of the lead developers of
wxf so don't
give me that nonsense stephen okay i
thought dorian was the main person
uh he and
under the strict supervision of me and
rob schofield okay all right fine
um go to possible issues at the very
bottom
um uh
is this not well it says packed arrays
of floats do not round trip when
serialized
all right so maybe it's on oh you want
to binary serialize rather than binary
deserialize
but this seems like the relevant thing
um
but okay um
but there's an even more fundamental
issue
again go to the very bottom there we go
okay
what am i seeing here you're seeing
something
that right it's because it's
because wxf has this
uh you know special form for
transporting associations
things that require validation don't get
marked as valid and therefore do not
get made atomic
this seems like a bug it's
well it's it depends what you're trying
to do
but w you know the only thing
that can completely faithfully reproduce
expressions is the kernel
it's the only thing so put and mx which
go through the kernel are completely
faithful
okay i'll make a different argument my
argument would be
when you say store a data set or
something
[Music]
i mean for something like sparse array
i'm very confused by this i'm sorry i'm
very very confused i don't understand
what it is
that there's some valid flag that's not
being set or something is that the issue
well it's that it
uh it's
the way it's constructed essentially i
mean right it's
it hasn't been turned into a t-rational
from from a t-normal because of of the
way
you know okay that why isn't that just a
bug
because because it happens in a library
that lives outside the kernel
and the kernel is right the cr right
it's being careful not to
val evaluate things in order to because
it doesn't want to create evaluation
leaks
okay so let me walk through this let me
walk through this again so you're saying
wxf which is consumable by things other
than the kernel
and implemented outside the kernel yes
does not contain does
not maintain okay when you do binary
serialize that is coming from the kernel
so the kernel could put whatever tagging
it wants
into that expression correct
up to a point right but
it's the basic issue that full form
doesn't isn't actually full form
right you can have it right i mean that
is the basic issue
okay fine but why is wxf
not putting tagging information which it
plainly knows
when it's created by binary serialize
well when it if it
well because most clients wouldn't
know how to do that i understand that
that's fine but but
well but i well
i would i'm i would have to think
through
the implementation i i don't know
okay that the colonel has certain
things which it knows and that
it tags those things
and other clients just ignore those tags
those kernel special tags
i mean that that may or may not be
possible
okay but why don't you look at that
because that seems like i i will i will
give it all the consideration it
deserves
i mean yeah that doesn't sound good
given that comment i would like to hear
that dorian if it is rejected
i want dorian to reject it as well all
right
but um you'll notice that this example
was written by dorian so if dorian
thought this was a bug
that you could just fix he would have
done it but it was under your cast so
okay roman and then he wrote he wrote
this example and
he wrote this example independently of
me so okay okay goodbye
okay roman yes i mean there are similar
problems with
sending stuff through wsdp or muslin
which i encounter all the time is
parallel computing
it's all these data types with with
hidden with hidden stuff
like solutions of differential equations
or interpolating functions or stuff like
that
and there the problem is that on on the
remote end when you restore the value of
a
symbol it doesn't go through the
evaluator so it never restores to
that stuff so i mean we have we have
cases where
we do not do as well as we should
are you using wxf in in the power oh no
i
i mean for for for parallel tools right
and
and and and the first the first
implementation of wxf
used math link and and therefore
it was subject to all those same
limitations then dorian did a second
implementation
in the kernel with so the the
right so you remember there was a v7
there
right the init when it was still
experimental it had version seven
of wxf and then when it we
de-experimentalized it it went to
version eight
so the the version seven implementation
was based
on math link and then version eight is
directly in the kernel and it's
therefore
more accurate in some ways but then it
it actually introduced a different set
of edge cases
because of that all right but what
you're saying is there's a general
problem
that faithfully rehydrating
a an expression because of its internal
tagging information that is not carried
along in full form
is difficult yes okay so i think that's
an issue that we should
what we what it sounds to me like we
have to do
is to have a full full form that has
some kind of wrapper
that's called you know you know has a
rehydrate wrapper or something
which is special and which is treated by
the
by the rehydrator independent of
evaluation
something like that yeah i i would
well i'm not i'm not going to
to accept or reject that uh uh off of
five seconds of thought but
i would certainly want to consult with
people like tom
and mark fine but i think but it sounds
to me like this is a general problem
that we need to solve that the kernel
knows stuff it's sending it through a
channel
which can go to other things which will
ignore those pieces of tagging
and how do we how do we how do we
present tagging that is not visible in
full form is the question
right right so i think we need a
solution to that
um i mean the current situation is the
problem is we
either have faithful representation with
mx and then it's not portable but
if you want to make it portable then it
doesn't work so fine so we need a
transfer
form right we need some kind of thing a
transfer form type
thing which is some kind of potentially
quite ugly
symbolic expression form that contains
enough tagging information that it can
be rehydrated
completely faithfully so
with with respect to this comment here
local object is clearly fine to use mx
files yep
okay the cloud
right i guess the question there is is
the limiting factor the input form
or or the
uh or the uh
or the network speed and i suppose
depending well
the right mx versus versus input form
can
make huge changes in the size of the
file so let me make sure
let me make a suggestion assume that you
press the cloud button
maybe it should extrude a sub button
that asks you do you need this to work
on 32-bit systems
default no or alternatively we could
just have a setting
that by default because i think that's a
really bizarre
you know i think it's a corner case i
don't think it's going to be very common
i you know
i mean i don't know what other 32-bit
things may be arising in the future but
i have to believe that they're a dying
breed
they do seem to be a dying breed um
i'm not sure by the time
microcontrollers aren't
you know i don't know what that what
they're at these days but
but yeah right i mean even i mean the
raspberry pi still supports 32-bit
operating systems but
even that right the raspberry pi itself
is
is no longer a 32-bit system
oh is that right why does it os support
i mean so you can run multiple os's on
it
yes uh i uh well i mean you've been able
to for a while
right i mean they have their own rasp uh
their own distro but then there are
other
there are other linux distros but you
can do both uh
their own distro 32-bit
um yes i mean the
the the one that supports 64-bit is the
raspberry pi 4.
and but they decided to run the old os
so they had the same distribution for
all of their
i think all of this stuff but there is a
64-bit version
uh for the from from the from the
foundation for the
west report by four so we need to port
our
our system to to support that i mean it
well i mean well i mean there's a bigger
question of do do we actually want to
just have a 64-bit arm linux
product because i think i mean
especially
right 64 i mean arm is
you know becoming obviously a much
bigger
thing uh on the desktop separate issue i
mean this is the right success of almond
servers we've had discussions with arm
and other people for years about this
issue
so it's different different topic there
um okay
but the question here is what to do in
the cloud case
how much slower is it um
well on the cloud i guess i haven't
timed it in the local object case i
i mean i i've gotten speed ups of like
you know four minutes going down to
to 10 seconds right it's
okay well let's check it for the cloud
my guess is we're going to want mx files
on the cloud
and my guess is we're going to want some
setting or some warning
something which is for now a this won't
work on 32-bit systems
right except on the raspberry pi where
it would need to say this won't work on
64-bit systems
right right
i would say in the case of 64 bits i
would say
this won't work on legacy 32-bit systems
for people who are can you know who
might otherwise be confused it's like
just don't worry about that
if you don't know what it means you
don't worry about it
right okay um
okay the ones store and an object are
clearly marked
don't clearly show that they're not
actually caused right so so actually
click the the store and local object
button in one of them
i hate this multi-click array
okay right so i mean right
so if you copied that output
and did hold of paste
and evaluated that you would not see
hold of sparse array you would see
hold of get of lo local object or
whatever
right and i don't understand this so if
i do hold of the
what the heck happened here that pink
yeah i've i've noticed that i don't know
i i haven't hunted that down and maybe
we need to start that down
okay hold of this oh weird weird weird
right because it you know right that
that get needs to evaluate to
actually
you know so it's just the fact that it
says data stored in a local object
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
so when this evaluates
i don't understand why it's asking me to
store now again because because that's a
new sparse array
right it's gone through the evaluator it
imported it it created a new sparse
array
it's just the same way as if you did
percent right it would
it's formatting the object again
right if you just evaluate percent now
right yeah i i get it i get it i get it
i would argue i mean a luxury feature
might be in this case where
it knows it came from a local object if
it was able to give that as the default
in the store now that would be luxury
i don't think it's strictly that's so
you got what i'm saying in other words i
i i get
i i understand what you're saying i i
just don't know
how it would have to be tagged in the
spot right
yeah i mean i i think like
this i think the sparsery formatting
code would need to
like have a hash table of known sparse
arrays and it's that
no it could be in there it could be in
the tag tagged in this thing when it
goes through and evaluates it
uh sparse array could spawn has all
kinds of crud inside it
it could have something which indicates
what kind of storage it's expecting
it's persistence location
i i have a hard
time seeing that
right i mean why doesn't it just have
an option in the sparse array that
determines
what that display item will be
um
right well for one thing i mean if you
just generate a sparse array and then
you decide to
save it then oh i see it doesn't no it
doesn't it's already been built
right i see what you're saying
well but when you evaluate that input
it's evaluating
some construct that does know what was
in it right
um when you evaluate this i could copy
this
that's some kind of box structure which
has been changed by me clicking here
so when that box structure is evaluated
the parsing of that box structure
can introduce a tag that is then carried
forward
in the kernel version of the expression
that's a positive yeah i would
think i don't want to commit to anything
without talking to rob
right and and that right and that's
something that will i mean
it's not going to be the item it's not
the most important thing right
it would sort of need to be done on an
object by object
basis all right okay so put it on the
side for now okay but
let's ask about it okay let's go back to
this
when else would you see this
um convert to input form convert to
standard form
on that input right yeah so if you if
you selected that
in of 10 and did shift command i then
you would definitely see it
here's a comment
if we think this is bad and it isn't
great
we could have a decorator function on
the outside that does nothing
evaluation-wise
but is merely a formatting wrapper
right like remote storage or whatever
we're calling this
you know remote stored remotely stored
object
right it has a format value but its
evaluation
is basically return my my argument
yep yeah that's a
that's a possibility um
have a think about that i mean this
isn't heinous what it's doing right now
although i have a bad feeling that there
will be cases like in documentation and
things where this might get heinous for
reasons that we don't expect
all right on to the next item if we can
okay
uh comment on our live stream about
semantic import but let's
take a look ben is saying i see semantic
importers on the agenda hopefully the
issue has been addressed where returned
results
are not being updated when data changes
okay right so there yes
so symantec import as
was written by tali however many years
ago
does some sort of automatic caching and
if you
don't know about the secret automatic
caching you can keep calling semantic
import and it gives you old
um and um right
and so at one point we were going to
rewrite semantic import
from scratch because it's written in go
and
basically you know once tally stopped
working on it there was nobody
to work on it um but then sarah king who
was working on that left so
it's just sort of um you know
languished i guess is the word um
so so there's the specific issue of
semantic import
so so i i see here uh that specific
import question and then sort of there
were
sort of two two sort of more general
issues
one about do we need some sort of
persistence location for caching that
somehow gets auto cleaned up
and there's a uh so this is in fact
about caching i mean the the thing that
was on our agenda here is in fact about
caching
yes although from about a different
perspective
right and right now it's got a caching
leak basically
horrifying okay let's start off with the
beginning why is it caching
jeremy i think for better or for worse
you're the world's uh
you're the remaining expert on semantic
import
i've never known anything well i
shouldn't say i've never known anything
about semantic import but i
sure don't know the cache and
how that works and why it exists other
than
um to ask the author and actually maybe
i should have thought
uh this is this is my bad uh if somebody
can try to get stefan
r he as head of qa he has gone in an
occasionally fixed critical
issues so he may be able to give us a
better answer but i don't know that
first of all
you know we could ask tally he does
exist and it's heard from
all right but i mean the
look semantic airport was originally
built as an experimental thing
and um i don't even know what categories
of input it deals with at this point
whatever tally originally wrote because
it doesn't
i mean and this is another set of
complaints right it doesn't integrate
with all of the spellings that are used
by the entity framework
and so whatever okay so look
it's actually an interesting hybrid of
that if i remember right maybe i'm maybe
i'm misremembering and i'm confused but
i thought we hooked it up to interpreter
so when it's
built into semantic import like person
or
city then you get the thing where half
the time it doesn't recognize it because
yeah okay okay
i get it so there's three different
frameworks that we could be using here
one is the local wolfram alpha framework
which doesn't exist yet but hopefully
jeremy is getting much closer
is that true statement it is true that
hopefully we're getting much closer
okay all right but i mean if we had that
then semantic import could use it true
statement that is that is exactly the
plan
is to is the rewrite from scratch of
semantic imports to use that
okay fine all right what it's doing
right now is using bloom filters and
things like this
right it is using a different case which
is an interesting case where you have a
large collection of things that are
thought to be of an identical type
um you know for the work
we're doing with our friends at
microsoft that's a another case where
that has the same
type of form factor of a large
collection
of data all of the same type or all
assumed to be of the same type
right so that's a that's another case
um there probably are some nice demos
out of
of using our stuff as part of excel
that um uh that show what we're talking
about
um let's see but but but i mean so
i don't know right that that's a
different use case for an
interpreter is interpreter where there's
a collection of identical objects
right i'm sorry i got a little
lost in that sentence okay all right the
okay semantic import uses a different
approach
for figuring out whether a column of
things
is all of a particular type i believe
that is true
i mean don't ask me to write don't ask
me to read the go code
but i believe that is a true statement
okay
okay it is using bloom filters to do
that
okay okay uh which by the way i believe
are now part of our data structure
system
so we actually have a uh you know a
top-level implementation efficient
top-level implementation of those where
we yeah i'm looking very forward to it
it exists yeah no well it exists but not
for use by alpha servers yet yes right
okay so hopefully really soon
complete silence from jeremy on that
okay
anyway um all right uh
okay but i mean to me
semantic import is something that should
be taken over by the machine learning
group
and well i don't know it's it's a merger
of what we
you know there's a machine learning
component and there's a well from alpha
nlu component
but what we're trying to solve here is
something much more mundane
which is just the fact that it has a
caching leak
right is that correct
it caches for a reason we don't even
understand but that caching is leaking
is that correct i believe that is true
okay so maybe we should figure out what
it's caching does anybody know what it
is caching
it's caching interpretations presumably
uh i think it's worse than that i think
it's
caching the actual file right so it
downloads the file and sticks it and
via some determin possibly via some
deterministic
okay so mechanism so if it uh you mean
that the same
named file if it's red again is
thought to have the same data in it even
if the file has been updated that's kind
of
lame it's kind of wrong caching i i
well i think uh i think it's sort of the
same url
if i recall correctly fine so that's
obviously wrong
right so i don't know where the urls
these days
accurately report their update time do
they
didn't someone talking about that i
understand what yeah it's going to be a
server-dependent
question i think that probably is not
yeah
for example local cache i do that i
check the update time of the
of the url then decide whether i should
update the cache
do you think you get it right well if
the server
if this it depends on the server but
nowadays i think web servers
and other kind of servers up are pretty
good at this because it it's really
saves a lot of bandwidth
okay fair enough so then we could assume
that but so then this cache may not be
correctly
getting invalidated when the http
response packet
you know http response can does not
contain the correct update time
so that's a bug which we should go fix
yeah and is it
that or is it that semantic import isn't
even
uh making a head request or something to
the url because it just assumes that it
should use the cache
well right so it needs to get a response
from the url
um
um yeah ben is pointing out that that
all this automatic interpretation is
nice but that there are other reasons to
use
um semantic import just because it's a
convenient way to package things into
data sets and so on
hopefully import is becoming better at
packaging things in data sets
but okay let's just go back to the
original questions okay so first point
let's find out why the cache isn't being
invalidated
okay fair yep okay
so now the question is what should the
cash be whatever the cash
is if it's a reasonable cash why isn't
it just using local cash
that didn't exist at the time fine so
let's look into it using local cash in
which case it would have the same
uh you know cash cleanup that local cash
has
fair sure
i i guess i'm not super familiar with
local cash so i i had forgotten
that we had such a thing um
[Music]
right uh but i i did also want to bring
up this sort of second
the second thread about sort of changing
uh dollar temporary directory and
and it's still not entirely clear to me
what the
purpose of this change is
so maybe roman you can yes i mean the
the only purpose is to hide
all the ugly mess that we create in the
slash temp directory
and there's no there's no suggestion to
clean up to delete
files or source but we'll just use a
sub-director different the current temp
directory now it was pointed out that
this contradicts the documentation but
it's already what we do on the mac right
on the mac your dollar temp temporary
director
is some user-specific one but the slash
temp still exists and
masslink still puts its stuff there
neatly packaged into a subdirectory so
well but it's still the dollar temporary
directory that the os
gave it right that's not that i i don't
understand
that directory structure but
it's exactly the same for every
application and if i look into it
it's got all sorts of files from all
sorts of random applications
just yeah okay so let me understand
so first point is trust the operating
system
let it give us the name of a temporary
directory
right which is what it does fine second
my suggestion is that we put our stuff
in a subdirectory just for cleanliness
yeah i think i tend to agree with that i
mean
the first your first point use what the
operating system gives us
does not force us to put everything
at that level we should for our internal
purposes create the subdirectory that is
the idea would be that the use of
visible dollar tempo directory and
create directory create file
and so on would work as now but
internally
we would use a different version of this
of these functions and put
our stuff into a subdirectory now this
would be a gradual process obviously we
don't
uh because we i don't know how many
places there are that use internal
create terrible way okay well so so that
that sounds different from what you send
said in the email because indeed yes i
mean
i'm not my point is to to clean up that
mess
and if we gradually change the way we
internally use
temporary files and we put them into a
subdirectory of our own then
i'm quite happy about that and then
i mean okay we don't need to change the
the use of visible
value but it means changing internal
changing code
of potentially sure a large number of
packets and
c code and top level code right so it'll
take a while to get done yes i mean it
doesn't have to be done
in one one step it might be a gradual
process so
i think there's one other thing that i
might suggest which i don't know whether
it's a good idea or not but
you know i guess with browsers when you
say that clear the browser cache
that cache is not in temp directories
that cache is in user directories right
correct it's in the the equivalent of
the library directory
okay do we have a clear the library
clear library directory button somewhere
in in um
in system preferences i
don't think so i mean we have
we have uh right we have clean start
which
deletes that right
well what what do you mean by clean the
light clean the library then right
because
i mean something like
somewhere in here and this is a this is
really needs to be updated all this
stuff somewhere in here
just like there's a reset to default so
whatever somewhere in here
there should be a thing that says clear
my
you know clear my local files directory
what is local files directory
right is that dollar user base directory
it's what
what is what is ios wherever local
objects are kept
yes i mean that that would actually be a
good yes
so clear all the local objects
i mean at least the ones in the default
dollar local
uh local base i mean
yeah in a perfect world right we would
have those things so cash is for example
um right so basically clear dollar local
base is what you're talking about
i think so but it might be nice to have
a management based directory there are
two directors which
we should offer to clear which
cash-based directory
which is what which is the cash for the
entity store and
well for for local cash and and other
resource functions and stuff like that
yeah i mean the entity framework is
still sticking things in dollar
user-based directory now it should i
mean cash stuff should
for example on my system i've configured
it that the
those caches are on the fast local disks
and s this is on my home directory which
is
network mounted so that's useful this
distinction between the two
okay let me make a suggestion okay so
we've clearly got lots of
functions that put random caching data
in random places
we should slowly try to inventory all of
those and try to make them consistent
point one point two we should set it up
so that
um something in preferences allows you
to manage the cache directories
and manage the local base directory the
cache directories
presumably if you blow away the cache
nothing terribly bad will happen
it will just start to reload
that's what that that is that is the
what is supposed to happen
right that is the purpose of a cache
directory things that if they
disappear can be regenerated yes right
right which is different from dollar
user-based directory i agree
things like preferences which obviously
would be i mean sometimes you want to
clear them but
usually you don't right so to me the
cash thing
is just clear the cash boom press this
button it'll close the cash
um in a perfect world you would say
clear cash
stuff that's more than 30 days old or
something see what i'm saying
although i don't i don't think anybody
offers that button like if you go into
your browser i think they have a clear
cache now but i don't think
they have uh clips
i'm not sure but i mean caches are often
hashed and
it's not even clear what that means fine
fine
clear the cache is fine but i mean the
main thing is my computer is running out
of disk space what do i do
let me go
browsers will offer to like clear your
history or downloads
no i see yeah right after a certain
amount of time okay so that's a little
different because that has a historical
tagging
okay so in local objects there might be
more segmentation there
of clear these things but don't clear
these things and in a perfect world we
would have
better information there so we could say
manage local object store and you could
select yes actually one thing that i
think we should have fairly soon is
is a particular button to clear
all the persistent initial
initialization
because that's the kind of stuff that
might bite you if you have something in
there
you don't even know where it is well
look the first thing that i would like
to see and i thought we were getting
this and maybe even as a function
repository thing
is just show me what the initializations
actually were no that's another
item on my agenda that that's that's
part of the original design of the
initialization system for hours of for
you right
right but i mean even even just uh for
diagnostics purposes having that as a
function repository item would already
be useful
right even before it's built in yeah
there's something
is it called initialization objects or
something okay
well all right so that's that's a thing
to worry about but let's let's go on and
see if we can just get through this
quickly and then
we have to wrap up
level ignores heads true for negative
levels
oh boy
okay sorry i was muted and and therefore
you were ignoring me
uh so i'm not i mean these last two
items are neither time
sensitive uh so if necessary we can we
can
let's let's just have one crack at this
okay
right so right so
all right so this is right so this is
right so i think for the place to start
right you have this compound expression
and you ask for negative
levels and and i mean we're using level
as an example this actually applies to
sort of
all all things that might take level
specs
um and you say and you use the default
heads goes to false then you get the
things that are right not atoms but sort
of
one level above the leaves in the tree
and if you
look at this tree that represents
your the expression then right we see
that
g uh g of five of y
z is sort of uh
you know is one level up from the bottom
and that's consistent
with uh with sort of heads uh
the question is are you counting depth
in a head or not
right now that's the question right
counting depth
when when you're using negative levels
does if if
if i have a very very deep head
does that count towards my leveling for
the things which are the arguments of
that head
is that correct
um i think it is correct
yes i think so yes
okay so if i were to say if i would say
yeah you've got one here
that's a deep head right
this thing here if i say depth
of that
why isn't that four am i confused
because uh you're using
uh yeah well right because you have a
compound head
so you just have blank of h of four
so it's three so three is quite so depth
does not go into that so if i say depth
of
f of g
of h of k
of x i see that that
depth is ignoring the head the headdress
so to speak right because because the
default is heads goes to false
okay all right so then when heads goes
to true
you're asking what is on level minus one
and the answer is here what's on level
minus one
so if i say level here
and i say on level minus one
right they're all at level minus one
because they're all
right the head right if you do the tree
visualization
that you have well the trivial tree
visualization that we'll get from the
next
section so if you go look at the next
section
right
right then we get trees that look like
that
right so if you put your your
[Music]
right but if you if you look at the
depth
uh
right so the issue is it's using the
depth when it sort of laying out the
tree but not one that's actually
the heads goes to true when it's laying
out the tree but not when it's
computing the depth is that a good way
to put it in
or do you have a better exactly right
yep it's like when you say heads goes to
true
you're allowed to find matches in the
head but you still
are always computing depth as though
heads goes to false
you're far to find matches in the head
for what purpose
for something like cases or something
right or you're right how you're now how
you're navigating the treatment
is like if you do level and you specify
some level spec
by match i just mean a part that's on
that
on one of those levels
right the level spec refers yeah yeah so
head
goes to true allows the level spec to
find
expressions in the head but it still
always uses
heads goes to false for the depth yeah
and
and stephen if i may i just want to say
that it took
ian and me uh
a good hour and a half i think to
prepare this agenda item in a way that
was
clear to two of us so i'm not sure that
rushing
this discussion at the end is giving it
its full consideration
but my guess is that what you what i
think you'll write that will need a
heads goes to something other than
true false right
because you're saying one of them is
looking there for something and the
other
is count levels
from what's in the head yep yeah
okay so heads goes to true means look in
there
but it doesn't sort of change how it's
computed once you're
there right
and so you see this contradiction that
when when you compute the depth with
heads goes to true you get
sort of different answers when you just
compute
depth yeah right
so that five six versus three three
well okay so hold on hold on
right i just i'm just trying to think
about whether full is the right
because essentially what's happening is
are the heads sprayed out
as part of the expression tree or is it
packaged up
into you know into this atomic thing
that is the head
that's that's the main question if it's
sprayed out if it's
if the heads are being treated like a
zero earth element of the expression and
the whole thing is just
it happens to be the zeroth element but
otherwise it's just the same as
everything else
then you'll get this behavior where it
counts the levels am i making sense
but if inside if the head is
encapsulated into an atomic thing
then it won't you know then you won't be
counting the levels
make sense
ian i that i i think i might miss
something but
you listed two cases and there are three
cases
okay okay okay but the two here say
listed i don't think they're completely
silly
one of them is right so the first one
you listed is
the only thing that makes sense for tree
level
like for trees in general because they
don't they don't have a
heads goes to true or false
well no i i'm saying the following okay
you have an expression
okay it's got some weird thing packed in
its head
okay
one way to think about an expression is
it is an array
with a zeroth element that is the head
okay right if you do that
then recursing down the zeroth element
is just like recursing down the first
element
it has the same level constraints right
right
the same depth thing as that would be
the consistent way to handle it which is
what we're calling heads goes to full or
heads goes to all no i understand that
that that's but so what i'm saying is
paige
that right that that i don't know
whether it's consistent or not i mean
it's a different way to handle it it is
as if
the head is just the zeroth part of the
of the
of the list which is the collection of
arguments
right as opposed to the other case where
the head
is treated as this atomic thing and
heads goes to false
is it's atomic don't go anywhere inside
it don't don't even look inside
it okay heads goes to true is look
inside
but don't treat it as another piece of
the expression
just treat it as a special thing that
can be looked inside but does not
otherwise it doesn't it's its depth is
irrelevant to the depth of the rest of
the expression
that makes sense yeah so i think those
are the cases
and now the only question is what the
name of the case where it's treated as
the zeroth element and sort of
integrated into the expression should be
agreed
so our choices are things like automatic
full all
so what's the right explanation of it
it's it's a case where the heads
well really what it is
the heads are treated like parts of the
expression
the zeroth part of an expression is
treated like just the first second third
part of an expression right
that's what it really is about correct
correct
i mean for some reason the inherited
comes to mind but i don't think it's
right
um
all is a bit confusing go ahead well i
was going to say that all
i mean this way of thinking of it all is
right well the problem is the left-hand
side right the reason i was
i was about to gravitate towards all is
because
we're treating all parts sort of equally
but that doesn't make sense given that
the left ha left hand side of the rule
is heads
right um
so i almost think heads goes to all
makes sense for what we're calling true
find matches in all of the heads but
you're not treating the head
as like part of the tree
okay but what would you do to treat this
part i mean we could grandfather
we could we could leave heads because
true does what it currently does and we
could we could prefer
heads goes to all but i'm not sure that
that that doesn't solve the problem of
what it means to it's basically
integrate the heads
integrate the head as a part of the
expression it's kind of a way to
describe what we're talking about
brett do you have a suggestion are you
or roman or anybody here yeah i was just
thinking as somebody who uses full and
all a lot he yes
might have some insight
and if you're speaking you must oh no
i'm thinking
okay the other way to think about it is
heads as
if i go through something i would prefer
full over all
yes you know just because of the true
false nature of the other
settings but
okay i could imagine describing it as
heads are treated in their full
form somehow saying that it's a you know
a head is treated in
as a full expression yeah perhaps
it's a little bit of a hack
where else do we have this issue of when
something is atomic versus when
something is treated
in in its fullness so to speak
[Music]
well anyway i think we've identified
what the issue is full is
is a reasonable start maybe there's a
better choice
but that seems pretty good to me there's
a bug in the tree visualization there
that x which is right to chase into the
other expression
yes roman yeah well this is
this uh we we know that the ian is still
working
on this so there's a reason why it's
only in the prototype build
um yeah maybe we saved this one for
given that we're 45 minutes over time
maybe we saved this one for next time
we're only 15 minutes over time whatever
we're over some time okay but but this
particular thing
right so this is basically the symbol
that was
i mean looking at the history and where
it's used it was
rand seemed to have been added maybe
maybe even by roman
i think for i like this symbol i mean i
i think it's a good
difference from aborted aborted says
that's right except except nothing uses
it and the things that would naturally
use it are now using failure objects
so the question is i
see my immediate reaction was that
it must be easy to recognize a timeout
and if i have to look
inside some arbitrary failure object
that everybody creates a little bit
differently than
how would i know that this failure is
actually a time out rather than
something
else i think we need this in a separate
meeting
let's get a list of what things produce
supports fail
you have the list there i mean if you
open those things
uh right or i guess only one of the i
guess i don't have the complete list of
failure objects but
basically everything else that i've okay
and ping time now
actually uh
uh uses it but everything else that we
found
was using failure objects i think
christopher inventoried these things but
confirm
did anybody ask him um
i don't think so so we go i'll i'll ping
uh
devon make sure we we do that yeah sure
um and and yeah and so maybe if he has
something we can
right i'm pretty sure he went through
and figured out what functions produce
what because right what confirms yeah i
mean that first list of things that
return a dollar aborted i mean that is
absolutely the correct thing to return
because
it's literally doing an abort
so i don't think time constrained
returning timeout will be the right
thing to do
right
i mean and the question is but if you
say
see some other things become exhausted
like ping time
becomes exhausted and just says i give
up right whereas
full simplify with a time constraint
doesn't give up it still returns the
expression it just hasn't simplified as
much as it might have done
right i mean well full simplifies yet
another
difference right because there the time
constraint is how much it allows on each
rule so if the rule doesn't terminate
after
the time constraint it just says okay
ignore this rule let's
go on to the next rule in the list
right so
all right uh i think i think then uh
yeah so we'll inventory this and then
take this up in the future meeting
sounds good okay all right thank you
stuff guys
thanks thanks to folks on the live
stream